hey guys I'm chassie welcome to GameSpot
universes discussion of Westworld I'm so
excited we be talking about this I'm
with Austin whoa we're gonna talk about
well yeah please limit your emotional
effect thank you last night we watched
dissonance theory which was episode 4 of
West's world and so far probably the
best episode I've seen so far what do
you think a lot happened here still a
lot of unanswered questions oh there
will continue to be unanswered questions
but let's talk about Ford first so we
saw a different side of Ford Anthony
Hopkins is doing an amazing job and
there was a particular scene that I want
to refer to with him and Theresa talking
inside the park and with just a hand
gesture he was able to freeze the hosts
so what does this mean and what does it
mean for theories for the future like
yeah I think I mean okay so Ford I feel
like he was like the cuddly guy I really
like - he's like a grandpa of the park
yes and then like he said there's a
whole new side to him eating at the
Olive Garden early and yeah he just like
flipped a switch on it
he's definitely he has that kind of that
God mentality yes of the park
the fears of fathers apart but now we're
seeing this other side of him he's made
himself a god there absolutely so he can
freeze hosts at his will and he kind of
just asserted his own authority
he told Theresa that he knew about her
and Bernard yeah yeah and the fact that
he knows I mean I feel like that gives
us this insight that he he knows
everything that's going on in the north
so are all these other things the fact
that Bernard if he knows about Bernard
and Theresa does he know about Bernard
and Dolores having conversations he
probably does I would imagine I'd
imagine so - so what does this mean for
the future so I'm thinking that we'll
the host stopped responding to his
commands to stop once they become
sentient like will is that what he wants
maybe that's what he wants
ultimately yeah and that you know and he
is introducing all these new storylines
as well that we know about and I keep
seeing these flashes of religion of
crosses of churches of you know we're
having this God talk right and I
definitely think that's gonna come into
play quite a bit for these these hosts
on how are they gonna explain these
voices right and what they're going
through
maybe they turn to religion mm-hmm now
that that brings up a good point so
let's talk about Maeve last night so she
had a turning point there where she had
this recurring vision and so I'm
thinking is that on purpose does he want
that to happen for her does Ford want
that to happen for her or is this just
kind of happening because she got that
line of code from Dolores and now she's
starting to see clearer yeah that that
was Maeve is somebody I'm really
interested in because she's she's kind
of going on the same path as Dolores but
there's a different approach there you
know and she's having these more of
these realizations and when she pulled
those pictures out from under the that
was a great scene and that freaked her
out really bad and she's like what is
this and and then she saw the doll
because uh the Native Americans were
walking by and then the the doll fell
onto the floor so that kind of put the
thought in my mind that maybe this is on
purpose maybe this is part of Ford's
plan but who's to tell ya maybe all that
he wanted was for them to start thinking
for themselves and that's them thinking
on their own yeah and I completely agree
with you I feel like Ford is planting
these seeds he's he's moving these hosts
into you know having to deal with these
these new questions about existence yeah
so that scene at the end where Maeve
like pulls out the bullet and she
finally realizes like none of this
matters and so that's just such a
pivotal point for the show itself
absolutely
so where do they go from there yeah I
mean and you know that's the thing is a
you know I feel like now these hosts
all these questions and what where are
they going to find the answers right
maybe the maze me so there's been this
ongoing theory that Barnard is a host
and I'm one of those believers right
there we right yes
so we both believe that Barnard is a
host so let's talk about why that is so
there have been little clues here and
there but the latest clue last night was
Dolores talking about losing her family
and then she says it's the only thing I
have left of them the pain which is
exactly what Bernard said about his son
exactly even when they were showing
those shots of Bernard having the
flashback my son I was like man those
are so similar because the flashbacks
Dolores is having and everybody's having
now I guess but yeah I really thought
Bernard I've been paying a close
attention to his dialogue as well and
when he he's speaking to like his
apprentice and she's showing him that
rock that she thinks has Orion on it and
they're talking about that and he points
out that's not Orion Orion has you know
it doesn't have four stars in his bank
and I'm thinking you know he he I guess
my point is that they they talk a lot
about the host now looking to the stars
for answers and I felt like that was a
throw for him to say I've looked at the
stars for answers I've gone this path
I've walked this path before so that was
a something that stuck out for me and
another one was when he was in the
bedroom with Theresa and she was like oh
I'm done with you I've used you for what
I want to use you for it is like oh
that's all I'm good for huh
okay that's an interesting thing to say
what are they trying to tell us you
right what are they trying to tell us
here and also when Ford was talking to
Teresa at Barnard he's like he has a
sensitive disposition like that just the
way he was talking about him kind of set
something off for me I might be reading
too far into it but I was like that's
another hint that he's opposed I think
it's dead I think he's a host all right
well so let's talk about when the shows
taking place what do you think yeah okay
so I have this theory okay yeah tell me
okay if we're on the same timeline as
the Old West world which took place in
1973 the Michael Crichton's great world
it was a thousand adult thousand dollars
it was a thousand dollars a day to get
into the park and have fun well well in
Episode three
Logan mentions he doesn't spend forty
thousand dollars a day to not do what he
wants to do so if you take it apparently
it's forty thousand dollars a day to get
worse Westworld yeah so if you actually
run the numbers for inflation that ends
up being about a hundred and five year
difference from 1973 which would put it
around twenty seventy eight all right so
I'm thinking and is that the only
timeline we're seeing that's really hard
to interpret timeline when Dolores is
talking to Bernard and then he's like
someone might miss you like what's
happening in the park at the time like
where is she is she right there yeah
it's it's hard to tell
yeah yeah I think we're I think we're
being tossed around on timelines and
that's something that will you know will
get privy to later alright so let's go
back to the maze so Bernard tells
Dolores about the maze last night so
what do you think about the maze you
have any theories about this maze okay
is this a real name right and so there's
some stuff out there and some theories
going around about the whole kind of the
the picture that is the main and black
got from the scalp one of the hosts and
it is so similar to a native
Eric and like some images that they
would sow into baskets and things like
that at the Odom tribe interesting and
they call it the man in the mace and
it's supposed to be about your life
journey and you know just kind of this
just accepting and right knowledge in
what you're going through and being
aware so that applies applies directly
to the hosts and what they're going
through
absolutely and the that map that picture
is used to find etoy who is this God
within oh yeah he is the man in the mace
a man in the man so the idea is that he
he came to life he people the earth he
you know treated them like his children
but there was another person who was
like him they he started war than
fighting he ends up getting killed comes
back to life and now he lives in a
mountain okay so maybe that is who the
man and black is trying to find is the
man in the maze he doesn't know what
he's looking for though we don't we
don't know yeah it's so true I don't
know what the maze is yet but it could
be an actual maze it could not it could
be a path of clues it could just be a
wild goose chase but and I will say when
Ford was you know he has these like huge
construction things earth yeah all this
man I was like ooh is he also looking
for the man in the mountain or the man
in the maze right he could also be
looking for something like I think he's
chasing Arnold goodbye and I'm pretty
sure Arnold is a real person there were
some theories that Arnold wasn't ever
there but I'm pretty sure he was yeah
and I mean Arnold is you know I feel
like I'm trying to place Arnold in this
world and in place who he is or where he
is and and that's something I feel like
I don't have enough information on you
know we still need more clues about
Arnold so there's so many questions so
many things but the next episode is
called contrapasso which means suffer
the opposite in latin and that's a
reference to Dante's Inferno any
thoughts on that well you know I looking
at some of the titles for this season I
definitely think that they are trying to
give us some clues so I don't know where
that's going but
definitely interesting to see where it
takes us okay we can't wait to watch
more Westworld I'm chasidy that was
Austin thanks for joining us and we'll
be talking about contrapposto next week
so please join us and for all your
favorite TV shows movies and comic
coverage stick with GameSpot universe